okay if you are looking for a David
Pakman show message board or a place to
discuss politics with me with Pat with
other viewers
there is the david pakman show subreddit
we try to enforce a no obvious scrolling
policy we've got moderators there and
you can find this subreddit at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT I was
browsing the subreddit too smart this
morning and found a few interesting
discussions that I wanted to point out
to you starting with a poll which points
out finds that 71% of Republicans
approve of Donald Trump's handling of
Russia the numbers aren't surprising but
they are disturbing and this is
something I've been talking about for
for a while which is that for as long as
Republicans are in power and to the
extent that the Republican voters don't
really have a political appetite for
holding Trump and his cronies
accountable for what we increasingly
know went on during the 2016 election
you're not going to see any consequences
and the fact that 71% of Republicans
think specifically that Trump is
handling Russia well good luck good luck
holding him accountable unless Democrats
take over the House and Senate in
November
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit a user posted just caught my
75 year old dad watching David on his
tablet this isn't a big news story or
anything but it was genuinely surprising
to me to see my dad watching the David
Pakman show
he's pretty religious which sort of
causes him to lean more right-wing on
social issues but he said he really
enjoys David's perspective on things and
thinks he's a smart guy I just thought
it was funny and I wanted to share
he's been exploring YouTube pretty hard
lately and I've been wondering if he'd
ever come across any of the channels I
watch regularly this is great I mean
listen if you look at our demographics
as I just drop drop something on the
floor if you look at our demographics
yeah
we have overwhelmingly strong sort of
demographic skewing towards younger
people but the 65 plus audience even
though they're mostly like on Fox News
and PBS I guess our two big ones
for the 65-plus audience we have some of
our biggest supporters including some
great folks in Cambridge Massachusetts
and in New York City and in other parts
of the country who are in that 65 plus
or even 75 plus age bracket and that's a
great thing everybody is welcome here
also from the David Pakman show
subreddit should we be allowed to vote
online I've been thinking about this and
haven't come up with a good reason why
we don't allow voting online is it
possible to make the process secure if
so what are the counter arguments
against being able to vote online we'd
certainly have far more participation
what do you think I am very very big on
online voting Estonia is a small country
that is I don't know that geographically
it's an Eastern Europe but it's
considered sort of part of Eastern
Europe and I'm actually as part of a
bigger project in a few months I'm going
to be visiting Estonia and they have
modernized democracy in some very
interesting ways and they are exploring
the online voting angle or possibility I
think in the same way that voting in
person presents challenges that have to
be overcome and safeguards that have to
be put in place online voting is the
exact same thing and it would have the
huge benefit of increasing Bohnert voter
turnout I am hugely hugely for exploring
that lastly from the David Pakman show
subreddit when David takes calls
what is he jotting down on his notepad
this continues to come up and I write a
few things down number one I do write
down the caller's name because I don't
want to forget their name and if we take
a dozen calls back-to-back it's possible
that I might mix up somebody's name and
I don't want to do that so I write down
the name I will also if something we
come up with the YouTube titles for the
calls obviously after the calls because
time sort of moves in a forward
direction and we can't come up with
titles for calls before we receive them
and if something happens during the call
that I think would be particularly good
or appealing for the title I will I will
write that down and that's it I'm not
doodling I'm not
you know I I don't know what people
would imagine that I'm doing but that's
what I am doing and it's all part of the
pulling back the curtain at the David
Pakman show
questions about the show comments want
to discuss topics from the show with
other viewers nearly 7,000 of our
viewers and listeners now participating
on the subreddit at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t today's program is
sponsored in part by futur which is a
social forecasting game for your phone
or web browsers that allows players to
come together and compete with each
other to predict future events futur is
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market which is a
scientifically validated way of
leveraging the wisdom of the crowd to
better estimate the likelihood of future
events and there are a ton of different
topics including politics and here's how
it works you go on the app find a future
event that you feel confident enough
about to make a prediction and make a
bet on the outcome you think is most
likely to happen using the apps in-game
fake currency your prediction is Right
you're rewarded with more points and you
compete with others who are making their
own predictions to see who's the best
forecaster there's no real money or
cryptocurrency involved and that's kind
of the fun of it the whole point is use
this social network to prove how good
you are at predicting the future I have
an account on the futur app and I make
predictions and you can place your bets
based on my predictions as well go to
futur com to sign up and start making
forecasts it's totally free and it's
available on both Android and iOS and on
web browsers
that's fut you you are calm